I'd like to share briefly with you
before concluding some of the work that
we've been doing on urban China.
By the end of 2010,
the Chinese urban population was existed
estimated,
excuse me,
at 660 million people by 20,
30,
and additional 300 million people are
expected to have joined the urban ranks
of China by my by migration or birth.
Now,
according to Mckinsey,
as many as a quarter of total global
growth in liquid fuel demand in the next
20 years is expected just to come from
China's cities.
Shell's been working in China for some
time and we've recently considered
urbanization there as part of a project
which is looked more broadly at the
future energy needs of the country.
And one of the key insights,
and I think one of the most exciting
things that that study was able to find
is that by focusing on density alone are
in small to medium sized cities and
we're talking about creating a density
roughly equal to the average density of
London or or the density of Paris.
It could be possible to contain all
urban growth in China.
To 20,
30 within the existing urban footprint,
and we looked at something like 480
cities have of 100,000 to half a million
people,
uh,
in looking at this and that move alone
would save an estimated 75,000 square
kilometers of arable land in a country
which is crying out for arable land.
And that's an area almost the size of
Scotland.
And in doing so,
it would create the conditions by which
energy could be reduced and emissions
impacted.